in this case the authors claimed active
Vapors had 2.2 times the risk of cancer
as a control group but their logistic
regression showed that people who never
used cocaine heroin or methamphetamines
also had a 2.2 times higher risk of
getting cancer why didn't the authors
run with this finding that cocaine might
be a cancer preventative because it's
absurd and would likely have brought
ridicule according to the researcher's
data being white raises your cancer risk
by 2.6 times having a middle income of
between 25 000 to 65 000 raises your
risk 2.3 times the authors didn't report
these spectacular findings either this
paper is among the worst of the
anti-vaping articles that managed to get
published in respectable peer-reviewed
journals and cited by regulators and
legislators but even the best studies
haven't surrounded a key statistical
issue and they tend to distort the
evidence to make vaping look dangerous